das ist zdf heute live ganz herzlich
willkommen an diesem montagabend
wir blicken mal wieder muss man sagen
ins bundeskanzleramt denn auch heute gab
es wieder einen gipfel zwischen bund und
ländern zum thema wie geht es weiter mit
corona gab es allerdings die falsche
formulierung denn es gibt ihn noch und
was wir jetzt hier machen ist quasi mit
einem kleinen risiko verbunden denn wir
sehen wenn wir nach berlin gucken da tut
sich noch überhaupt gar nichts im
bundeskanzleramt die kollegen weit
warten weiterhin darauf dass die
bundeskanzlerin und die vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vor die
presse treten
und dass sie das nicht tun das liegt
daran dass es heute ganz schön geknallt
hat in dieser sitzung und das ist auch
der grund warum wir jetzt schon live
sind obwohl wir nicht absehen können
wann sich im kanzleramt was tut mein
schreibtisch hier am moderationsprozess
könnt ihr wahrscheinlich gleich sehen
ist voll von gelben zetteln und das
liegt daran dass hier mehrere beschluss
vorlagen liegen die seit gestern abend
aus dem kanzleramt kommuniziert wurden
in denen verschiedene maßnahmen standen
die ganz offenbar in den vergangenen
stunden von den ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten wieder kassiert
worden sind und jetzt ist die frage
worauf kann man sich heute einigen
ich freue mich darüber mit euch zu
sprechen freue mich auf eure kommentare
wie eure fragen und kommentare wie immer
in die kommentare und wenn ihr die zdf-
heute- app nutzt bitte wie gewohnt in
diese an diese e mail adresse und ich
freue mich dass heute an meiner seite
ist der virologe dr martin stürner
schönen guten abend herr dr stürmer sie
sind die rollo ge sie leiten ein labor
in frankfurt und sie sind auch dozent an
am institut für medizinische virologie
an der universität frankfurt schön dass
sie heute abend hier sind hat dr stürmer
und ich freue mich dass in berlin meine
kollegin nicole diekmann wieder mit
dabei ist halo nicole schönen guten
abend
was ist los im kanzleramt wie es die
situation woran hängt es
ja also wir sehen sehen wir im moment
nichts außer ein paar stühlen die die
abstandsregeln einhalten von einigen
kollegen besetzt sind
es gab schon im vorfeld dieses treffens
heute die ersten anzeichen dafür dass es
länger dauern könnte und dass das
einigermaßen kontrovers zugeht
du hast es ja eben schon gesagt es gab
seit gestern abend die erste
beschlussvorlage vom kanzleramt mit dem
das kanzleramt in dieser gespräche heute
eingegangen ist und das stieß bei
einigen beteiligten auch überhaupt keine
große gegenliebe
zum beispiel bei manuela schwesig
ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern die hat heute oft also für
jedermann und jederfrau nach lesbar
geschrieben dass man nicht damit
einverstanden ist dass aus dem kanzler
anbieter so etwas kommt und die
ministerpräsidentinnen die ja das letzte
wort haben de facto bei solchen
beschlüssen dass die quasi als
nachgeordnete instanz dadurch betrachtet
werden und das heißt ja eben auch schon
gesagt man sieht das jetzt an den
beschlussvorlagen ich kann da vielleicht
mal zeigen
ich weiß nicht ob man das sieht das hier
ist die beschlussvorlage wie die länder
sie gerne hätten und vielleicht sieht
man dass da hier ist alles
durchgestrichen das ist echt ein großer
passus und da fand strotzt diese
beschlussvorlage da wurde so viel
rausgestrichen dass man sich fragt was
da heute am ende noch warum kamen kann
was ich jetzt gerade gezeigt habe ist
ein punkt den das kanzleramt zuerst
vorgeschlagen hatte nämlich dass wir
sobald jemand erkältungssymptome an sich
verzeichnet man sofort nach hause geht
und sich dort für fünf bis sieben tage
in quarantäne gibt und auch möglichst
von familienmitgliedern isoliert das
haben die länder chefs und chefinnen
direkt kassiert und auch der große
themenkomplexe
schule das schreiben wir bestimmt gleich
noch ein bisschen drüber ist auch
komplett zerpflückt worden
dann würde ich vorschlagen wir schauen
gemeinsam mal auf eine zusammenfassung
dessen was denn in diesen beschluss
vorlagen stand und was sich das
kanzleramt denn so als maßnahmen
insgesamt vorgestellt hatte laut
beschlussvorlage stand heute mittag ist
es notwendig alle nicht erforderlichen
kontakte unbedingt zu vermeiden
daher ist der aufenthalt in der
öffentlichkeit nur noch mit den
angehörigen des eigenen und maximal zwei
personen eines weiteren hausstandes
erlaubt verstöße werden von den
ordnungsbehörden sanktioniert zudem soll
man sich zu hause nur noch mit freunden
oder bekannten aus einem festen haus
stand treffen kinder und jugendliche nur
noch mit einem freund oder einer
freundin auf private feiern soll bis
weihnachten ganz verzichtet werden
wer erkältungssymptome wie husten oder
schnupfen hat soll sich sofort fünf bis
sieben tage zu hause in quarantäne
begeben und vom arzt telefonisch
krankschreiben lassen corona test nur
wenn es schlimmer wird angesprochen was
davon ist dann stand jetzt übrig
geblieben
also stand jetzt ist davon ungefähr gar
nichts mehr übrig habe ja gerade schon
gesagt diese geschichte mit in
quarantäne ist herausgestrichen worden
und habe ich auch gerade schon
angedeutet es war eigentlich der plan
dass man noch mal sehr genau auf die
schulen guckt die sollen ja unbedingt
geöffnet bleiben das war vor zwei wochen
schon das klare politische statement die
schulen bleiben offen
anders als im frühjahr dafür hatte es ja
viel kritik gegeben dass die schon
beschlossen worden waren
und so stand heute also in dem ersten
entwurf des kanzleramts dass in allen
jahrgangsstufen das heißt also auch in
der grundschule durchgängig masken
getragen werden sollen auch während des
unterricht und zum beispiel die klassen
verkleinert werden indem sie in gruppen
unterteilt werden die dann auch
beieinander bleiben und durchgängig
getrennt voneinander unterrichtet werden
das war die erste idee die zweite idee
diana
dem kanzler an kamen nachdem man da
schon kassiert hatte war man gibt den
länder chefs und chefinnen jetzt eine
woche zeit um einen gegenvorschlag
vorzulegen
und auch das ist jetzt erst mal wieder
herausgestrichen selbst diese woche zeit
die man geben wollte die steht jetzt in
der aktuellen beschlussvorlage nicht
mehr drin die die länderchefs vorgelegt
haben nicole ich würd gerne gleich auch
die user kommentare und fragen mit
einbeziehen und natürlich auch den
standpunkt des virologen der natürlich
auch interessant ist bei all den fragen
was macht man jetzt was macht man nicht
möchte aber zunächst noch mal einen
gemeinsamen blick ins kanzleramt werfen
und die ich auch noch mal um deine
einschätzung bitten nicole wenn man sich
anguckt
da tut sich immer noch nichts und das
könnte an der situation liegen dass man
einen entwurf des kanzleramts hatte oder
mehrere und jetzt einen total
zusammengestrichenen anderen entwurf der
ja quasi ein gegenentwurf ist und jetzt
muss man irgendwie gucken wie man beides
zusammen bekommt denn am ende müssen ja
auf der einen seite der bund auf der
anderen seite die länder irgendwie
gesichtswahrend vor die presse treten
können und vor allem der bevölkerung
etwas verkaufen können was sie auch
mitgehen kann in welcher lage befinden
wir uns da jetzt gerade nicole pferd zu
sagen was ich nur sagen kann ist dass
wir normalerweise sitzt auch ein kollege
von mir gerade im kanzleramt bei dieser
pressekonferenz sollte sie denn
irgendwann mal anfangen das ding ist die
kriegen normalerweise luft vorwarnung
wann das irgendwann mal losgeht so in
den nächsten 20 minuten das ist immer so
der zeitraum und bisher regt sich da gar
nichts also anscheinend bitter immer
noch hart gerungen und es ist
tatsächlich wie du gerade schon gesagt
hast die frage ob man da jetzt komplett
ohne beschlüsse rausgeht was eigentlich
nicht geht bei dem was das kanzleramt
vorgelegt hat dann gehen wir doch mal in
die frage die wenn ich mir die user
kommentare angucke die meisten leute
beschäftigt hat dr stürmer nämlich die
frage werden die schulen geschlossen
unabhängig davon ob das jetzt
beschlossen wird was zum derzeitigen
standpunkt wie wir das hören
unwahrscheinlich ist ob das nächste
woche beschlossen wird ob das in
abgespeckter form beschlossen wird indem
man sagt wir brauchen hybridmodelle oder
wir brauchen irgendwie kleinere klassen
aus biologischer sicht sollte man
schulen schließen fragezeichen ja wenn
man jetzt aus psychologischer sicht
sieht ist natürlich jede kontakt
vermeidung die wir erzielen können gut
also eine schulschließung würde dann
natürlich zu beitragen die kontakte
deutlich zu reduzieren
auf der anderen seite muss man natürlich
immer schauen wie groß ist das
ausbruchsgeschehen was wir aktuell in
den schulen sehen
es ist nicht unerheblich das ist bei
weitem mehr als was wir im sommer
gesehen haben und auch die idee dass
kinder wenig bis gar nichts zu
infektionsgeschehen beitragen ich ja vom
tisch und insofern muss man schon
konstatieren dass kinder durchaus auch
infektionen bekommen können und diese
auch weitergeben können es ist natürlich
immer eine schwierige sache ich denke
man kann in schulen wenn man vernünftige
modelle macht das infektionsrisiko auch
deutlich reduzieren man muss nicht
gleich eine gesamte schule oder
insgesamt die schulen zu machen
man hat leider ein bisschen die zeit
verstreichen lassen hatte im sommer sehr
viel zeit sich vernünftige modelle zu
überlegen die waren so ein bisschen hat
verstreichen lassen
genutzt hat gelassen es gibt technische
möglichkeiten aero sohle zu reduzieren
in klassenzimmern
es gibt die möglichkeit neben
konsequenter mit masken zu unterrichten
für lehrer und für schüler im unterricht
gerade in weiterführende schulen
man kann die klassengrößen reduzieren
wenn man möchte man kann teilweise
präsenzunterricht teilweise
homeschooling viele möglichkeiten mit
dem man die komplette schließung
vermeiden kann ich denke immer noch man
sollte versuchen diese komplette
schließung nicht durchführen zu müssen
sie haben das mit der maske gerade
angesprochen das ist natürlich auch eine
frage die immer wieder auftaut und die
auch eine sache die heute auf dem tisch
liegt oder lag masken pflicht für kinder
egal welchen alters komplett während des
schulunterrichts halten sie das für eine
sinnvolle maßnahme also nicht in der
kombination das dann auch auf dem
schulhof in den pausen masken getragen
werden muss ich glaube dass einfach auch
gerade in einem bestimmten alter ist
einfach zu vieles für die kinder
permanent masken tragen zu müssen
und meine idee war auch kein fan gewesen
er die maske im unterricht tragen zu
müssen wo es eben einfach deutlich
gefährlicher ist weil dort ist der
geschlossene raum
dort ist die enge vorhanden und dass man
sich eher modelle und strategien
überlegt wo die kinder wenn man in die
pause geht auf dem
golf ist da die maske abnehmen zu können
um dort eine es durch abend ohne maske
ein bisschen zu ermöglichen das wäre er
mein konzept gewesen
ich würde gerne mal die zeit nutzen und
einen blick auf die zahlen werfen und
wir sehen hier die kurve die die zdf
heute da dargestellt hat der verlauf ist
ganz klar hier im früher sind wir im
märz am 31
bei knapp 6.000 neuinfektionen also
damals in der ersten welle quasi beim
pik und dann sehen wir über den sommer
hinweg entspannt sich die lage und
spitzt sich dann jetzt im herbst wieder
extrem zu wir sehen aber auch hier in
den letzten tagen kann man von einer art
stabilisierung auf sehr hohem niveau
aber nicht von einem weiteren
exponentiellen anstieg sprechen
worauf führen sie das zurück ich würde
das schon auch jetzt als auswirkungen
der syslog downlight sehen weil wir ja
doch schon einiges an kontakt
beschränkungen umgesetzt haben und man
sagt ja immer die zahlen laufen so ein
bis zwei wochen hinten an und
dementsprechend sind ja heute zwei
wochen her wo die maßnahmen gestartet
worden sind und ich denke auch im
vorfeld ist sicherlich bei einigen auch
was angekommen so ungefähr in der
hinrich mensch da ist doch jetzt einiges
an infektionsgeschehen und die einsicht
dass man vielleicht doch auch eben durch
selbstständiges und eigenständiges
reduzieren der kontakte was dazu
beitragen kann also ich glaube in der
konstellation kann man sich so dass
langsam abflachen durchaus erklären
wobei das natürlich nicht das ziel sein
kann dass wir auf dem hohen
infektionsgefahr bleiben weil wir ja
sehen dass das zu hoch ist um
letztendlich auch eine vernünftige
kontrolle wieder über infektionsketten
zu haben dementsprechend muss jetzt der
trend eigentlich auch umgekehrt werden
das heißt die fallzahlen müssen
eigentlich weiter sinken und die
inzidenz muss auch wieder deutlich unter
die 50 nicole nur meine frage an dich
und zwar aus politischer sicht beim
thema schulen du hast es auch schon
angesprochen aber das ist ein
riesenthema dass das bewegt die leute
sehr die frage werden die schulen
geschlossen
die virologische sicht haben wir gerade
schon gehört warum ist es so schwer
verliebt für die politik dann klaren
schritt zu gehen also klar das ist sache
der länder natürlich aber warum ist es
so schwer sich von bundesseite
durchzusetzen und zu sagen wir müssen
jetzt geregelt in einen betrieb gehen
der nicht jeden tag alle gehen in die
schule bedeutet sondern der eben einen
intelligenten umgang mit dieser pandemie
bedeutet und zwar halt dann jetzt ende
november wenn was nicht schon früher
hingekriegt haben ganz offensichtlich
na ja genau du hast es ja gerade schon
gesagt einmal wird der föderalismus aus
guten gründen ja auch zum teil hoch
gehalten
zum anderen was sind die alternativen
das gab gestern schon den vorschlag von
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
der vorgeschlagen hat man solle doch
hotels und restaurants die im moment eh
mehr oder weniger geschlossen sind
nutzen um dort kinder zu unterrichten da
könnten nämlich abstände eingehalten
werden
das passt auch zu dem vorschlag auf den
ersten blick der ja im ersten entwurf
des kanzleramts stand man solle die
klassen entzerren also in gruppen
einteilen da melden sich dann aber
wieder die minister innen aus den
ländern und sagen dafür fehlt uns das
personal das heißt dafür braucht man ja
auch mehr lehrerinnen zum beispiel das
nächste ist so vorschläge wie
homeschooling das haben wir ja schon
beim ersten so genannten lockdown
gewinnen das hat ja auch ganz in ganz
ganz vielen schulen überhaupt nicht
funktioniert das heißt in der theorie
mögen viele modelle funktionieren
in der praxis aber gibt es da große
große probleme und ich will noch ein
sagen weil das wie ich finde der
eindrücklichste appell war bei der
pressekonferenz nach dem vergangenen
treffen das war berlins regierender
bürgermeister müller
der hat da noch mal begründet warum man
unbedingt daran festhalten will
die schulen offen zu halten er hat sehr
klar gesagt dass die sorge groß ist dass
die gewalt in den familien zunimmt und
dass solche familien werden natürlich
entzerrt dadurch wenn die kinder
zumindest morgens einer angespannten
situation oder vormittags
der schule sind dann sind die eltern
auch nicht wenn wenn es kein
homeschooling gibt nicht im zweifel
damit überfordert die kinder weiter zu
unterrichten zu hause braucht es ja ganz
oft leben hinaus gelaufen ist wegen
mangelnder holmes kollegen konzepte und
zum dritten ist die schule auch immer
einen ort wo im zweifel auch entdeckt
wird dass es zuhause schief geht also es
gibt viele gründe dafür zu sagen die
schulen müssen offen bleiben natürlich
auch einen wirtschaftlichen grund denn
eltern die in ruhe arbeiten können
halten die wirtschaft natürlich er am
laufen wissen mit kleinen kindern holmes
bildung zu hause das ist ein grundstück
das kaum gelingen kann
ich möchte ganz neue fragen von usern
aufgreifen die du damit zum teil quasi
schon beantwortet hast aber es trotzdem
geht es darüber hinaus auf youtube fragt
wieso machen die nicht einfach für zwei
wochen alles dicht und ebenfalls auf
youtube youtube tm c warum wird jetzt
nicht hart durchgegriffen wie in
österreich gestern wie gesagt ein teil
dieser antwort zum thema schon hast du
gerade gegeben aber was sind gründe
dafür dass man sich in deutschland für
einen so harten lockdown durchringt wie
das ab morgen hier in österreich zum
beispiel der fall ist es gibt dieses
stichwort des jojo shutdowns den hat
markus söder der ministerpräsident von
bayern benutzt heute und auch gestern
der saarländische ministerpräsident hans
und auch malu dreyer
die ministerpräsidenten von
rheinland-pfalz hat gestern nochmal
gesagt wir dürfen die leute jetzt auch
nicht verrückt machen wir müssen jetzt
mal in ruhe erstmal abwarten was haben
die vergangenen zwei wochen gebracht die
angst der politik ist das vertrauen der
leute zu verspielen indem immer wieder
neue maßnahmen beschlossen werden nicht
erst mal abgewartet wird was haben eben
solche teil shutdowns die wir ihnen im
moment erleben gebracht und die akademie
wird ja nicht vorbei seien weder ende
november noch ende dezember das wissen
wir ja mittlerweile alle das heißt man
will jetzt auch nicht in
wellenbewegungen immer erst mal wieder
was lockern
in anführungszeichen und dann wieder
neue reaktionen auf liegen bei dann so
die befürchtung die geduld der menschen
dann ausgebracht ist denn die zustimmung
ist ja immer noch sehr hoch innerhalb
der bevölkerung für solche maßnahmen das
darf man nicht vergessen auch wenn
manchmal die die gegner die lautesten
sind und was aber noch dazukommt ist man
möchte nichts das ja auch gewählt werden
das ist natürlich auch knallhart aerial
politik wir haben nächstes jahr ein
super war ja fast schon ein mega war ja
inklusive einer bundestagswahl
und auch deswegen möchte man natürlich
die wähler innen nicht vertreten wir
gucken noch einmal gemeinsam gerade nach
berlin und sehen nach wie vor dass wir
außerdem verhältnismäßig wenig
attraktiven hinterkopf des kollegen den
ich an dieser stelle herzlich grüße und
nicht beleidigen möchte aber abgesehen
davon sehen wir einfach nicht viel
gerade in berlin und warten deshalb
weiter auf die pressekonferenz und
deshalb gebe ich gerne die frage auch an
den virologen weiter warum macht man
nicht alles dicht ab nicole diekmann
gerade aus politischer korrespondent in
sicht eingeordnet wäre es denn aus ihrer
sicht sinnvoll
jetzt zu sagen man macht alles dicht für
zwei wochen oder für vier wochen
ja wenn man es rein aus biologischer
sicht machen würde denn es ist
tatsächlich so wenn wir jetzt einmal
komplett auf die bremse treten und unser
leben in der form reduzieren wie wir es
beim ersten lockdown gemacht haben
vielleicht auch sogar noch ein bisschen
schärfer hätten wir natürlich eine gute
möglichkeit diese ganz groß bereite
infektions die ganz breite
infektionsgeschehen was wir in
deutschland haben zu reduzieren
dass das natürlich andere nachteile hat
auf wirtschaftlicher basis auf sozialer
basis unterbau war gar nicht drüber
diskutieren
das ist ja auch dem virologen klar ich
bin ja nicht nur virologie ich bin ja
auch ein bürger dieses landes mit
familie und kindern und weiß wie es ist
also schlagen zwei herzen in meiner
brust
wenn ich aber den anspruch habe
infektionsgeschehen wirklich in den
griff zu bekommen da muss ich mir eben
überlegen was was ist das was das virus
braucht um sich zu verbreiten und das
sind kontakte ohne die kontakte
untereinander kann sich ein solches
virus nicht nicht über die längeren
zeitraum
aufrechterhalten und dementsprechend
mehr natürlich die idee gewesen eine
14-tägige voll umfassende lock down
strategie zu fahren auch eine
möglichkeit gewesen man hat sich für
einen anderen weg entschieden
eben aus der erfahrung des ersten
lockdown den ich auch mit gegangen bin
und jetzt ist es natürlich so kann
darüber spekulieren ob wir jetzt zu früh
dran sind das schon bewerten zu wollen
ob man noch eine woche länger zeit geben
sollte wir haben wir heute den ersten
tag wirklich gesehen wo sowohl die
zahlen insgesamt runtergefallen sind
wobei wir das montags vergleich zum
sonntag ja immer kennen
aber wir haben auch tatsächlich heute
vergleich zum montag vor einer woche
auch eine deutlich geringere zahlen und
das wäre jetzt im prinzip so ein tag
wenn man den nächsten 2-3 tagen nochmal
sehen dass wieder das
infektionsgeschehen rückläufig ist dann
müsste man gar nicht über verschärfungen
diskutieren sondern könnte mit dem
status quo weiter agieren insofern kann
es durchaus sein dass das jetzt
abzuwarten eben durchaus sinn doch auch
gerade im kontext dieser gerade gehört
haben die menschen mitzunehmen weil ohne
die menschen in unserem lande machen
diese ganzen geschichten gar keinen sinn
wenn da die überzeugung nicht dahinter
ist weil wir den privaten bereich in der
form gar nicht reglementieren und
kontrollieren können
wir haben ein schönes beispiel das kino
hat zu was mache ich ich habe lust auf
den film ich glaub mir fünf sechs kumpel
ein und dann feiere ich ihm zu hause
sitzt da drei stunden vor einem tollen
film trinken papier habt keine maske auf
und schmuck habe ich dann fünf sechs
leute infiziert das ist die gefahr die
dahinter steht wenn aber das ins
bewusstsein kommt die leute mit man
sagen jawoll wenn ich darf da was auch
verzichtet
dann war all das was wir jetzt in den
nächsten letzten zwei wochen und den
nächsten zwei wochen machen nicht
umsonst weil wenn wir das nicht haben
dann bringt auch nichts danach den
lockten wieder zurückzuführen weil dann
haben wir diesen jojo effekt von dem er
gerade gesprochen haben weil dann haben
wir immer wieder situationen dass das
infektionsgeschehen wieder ansteigt und
dann stehen wir wieder vor der gleichen
wahl also da muss was in die köpfe der
menschen rein und das geht auch nur
indem man wirklich sinnvoll und
vernünftig argumentiert nun könnte man
ja nicole annehmen das ist in den köpfen
der menschen jetzt eigentlich drin also
ich meine der satz vermeiden sie kontakt
zu der ist ja eigentlich relativ
eindeutig ob man jetzt irgendwie mit
maske mit zwei oder mit vier leuten da
oder da hingehen kann das ist ja
eigentlich am ende nur kosmetik die
grundaussage ist ja da so wie es
österreichs kanzler kurz sagt treffen
sie nie
nun darf man das in deutschland unter
gewissen voraussetzungen und die leute
machen ist ja auch und wenn man sich
diese beschlussvorlage so anguckt dann
sind wir fast in einem diplomatischen
vokabular inzwischen wo man
unterscheiden muss wird jetzt der
botschafter einbestellt oder wird er
eingeladen zum gespräch werden wir jetzt
gebeten kontakte zu vermeiden wird uns
verboten kontakte zu haben wird an uns
appelliert kontakte zu vermeiden was
glaubst du ist dieses wenn das eine
strategie ist ist das eine gute taktik
um die deutschen mitzunehmen bei dem
verständnis für die maßnahmen
ich finde es ist auf jeden fall das
signal das man zugehört hat in den
letzten wochen weil die diskussion sich
auch gewendet hat auch das wie man das
so schön neudeutsch sagt geworden
es gibt ja auch die kritik daran dass
die politik den leuten nicht auf
augenhöhe begegnet sondern dass das wie
so ein dass sie das ist so ein so nanny
staat seine kommunikation gegeben habe
in den vergangenen wochen und es gibt
natürlich auch diejenigen die sagen der
staat greift so massiv in unserer
grundrechte ein
das kann so nicht bleiben und da ist
natürlich dieser korridor mit gesetzt ja
sozusagen auf der einen seite haben wir
als bundesregierung die verantwortung
hier möglichst die schäden der pandemie
einzugrenzen auf der anderen seite
agieren wir aber eben auch an die
eigenverantwortung der menschen denn die
sind ja alle erwachsenen das ist glaube
ich der versuch vor allem jetzt der
länder ja die ja aus vorschriften auf
klaren vorschriften vorgaben die das
kanzleramt in dieses papier
eingeschrieben hat appelle gemacht hat
man will nicht den eindruck erwecken in
der mehrheit derer die da gerade
zusammen setzen und verhandeln
man würde den menschen zu sehr ins leben
eingreifen sondern man möchte
anscheinend auch das gefühl vermitteln
dass man auch vertrauen hat in das die
vernunft der mehrheit in diesem land
nicole wir
sehen dass in berlin die kollegen mit
arbeits schwenks versuchen sich die zeit
zu vertreiben oder schon mal vor
arbeiten oder auch im internet die
meldungen verfolgen und warten wir
fassen mal kurz zusammen es hakt im
bundeskanzleramt
es lässt immer noch nicht hoffen dass
wir in kürze eine kanzlerin sehen und
zwei ministerpräsidenten die verkünden
auf was sie sich geeinigt haben denn es
gab mehrere vorlagen des
bundeskanzleramtes die quasi kassiert
wurden von den ländern
es gab mehrere maßnahmen die vom bund
vorgeschlagen wurden die von den ländern
offenbar nicht mitgegangen werden
eine frage zum prozedere an dieser
stelle liebe nicole beamte befragt auf
youtube wie genau werden die maßnahmen
denn entschieden in der aktuellen
besprechung abstimmung mit einfacher
mehrheit oder vetorecht für jeden
minister wir haben wir uns das
vorzustellen
dieses virtuelle treffen im also rein
theoretisch wenn ein völlig egal wie es
beim nächsten mal klimatisch ist wenn
man sich zusammen schaltet kann jede
ministerin ministerpräsident jeder jede
ministerpräsidentin kann sagen tragen
war mit und morgen erklären machen wir
doch nicht also man kann jetzt zusammen
beschließen maßnahmen anzugehen man kann
auch einen maßnahmenkatalog
zusammengeschlossen und unterschiedliche
punkte dann unterschiedlich handhaben
und so ist es die letzten monate ja auch
immer wieder gelaufen vetorecht rein
theoretisch hat jeder präsident jede
ministerpräsidentin vetorecht nochmal
das ist dass das ist ja das
infektionsschutzgesetz und dass es da
geht und das ist ländersache
darüber wird es ja auch eine große
debatte am mittwoch im bundestag geben
thema infektionsschutzgesetzes möchte
ich an dieser stelle aber gar nicht
aufmachen das fast das ist sehr viel
sehr viel stoff immer dem man reden kann
und auch muss das werden wir über zdf
heute live auch tun vielleicht sogar
noch heute abend je nachdem wie lange
sich das im kanzleramt noch aber ich
möchte gerne noch einmal den blick
zusammenfassen auf das was
dort im kanzleramt stattfand stattfindet
und auch über das was es an politischer
diskussion im vorfeld gegeben hat es ist
kurz vor 14 uhr als bayerns
ministerpräsident müller und berlins
regierender bürgermeister müller ins
kanzleramt kommen die anderen
länderchefs werden per video
zugeschaltet um die wirkung der vor
einer woche beschlossenen maßnahmen im
kampf gegen korona zu besprechen
wenn wir jetzt schaffen mit den
maßnahmen die wir jetzt treffen die
zahlen entsprechend niedrig zu halten
dann glaube ich können wir auch ein
vernünftigere weitere entwicklung haben
muss nicht alles zu machen und damit
nicht alles zu machen muss sollen solche
bilder weiter in der vergangenheit
angehören private feiern nur noch mit
einem weiteren haus stand kinder und
jugendliche sollen sich ausschließlich
mit einem einzigen spielkameraden
treffen dürfen weltfremd nennt das die
opposition
sie treffen sich in ihren klassen in den
schulräumen auf der anfahrt in den
bussen und straßenbahnen aber außerhalb
dieses komplexes wenn sie sich nur mit
einer weiteren person treffen
das ist nicht logisch das geht
vollkommen an der lebensrealität von
kindern vorbei das geht an der
lebensrealität von ganz ganz vielen
familien vorbei auch fdp und afd gehen
mit den bislang bekannt gewordenen
vorschlägen von bund und ländern hart
ins gericht pandemie bekämpfung hin oder
her wir leben das grundsätzlich ab
diesen diesen eingriff in die
privatsphäre
und wir werden einen demokratischen
mitteln versuchen das zu verhindern ich
kann die bundeskanzlerin oder das
bundeskanzleramt nur auffordern künftig
mit maximaler transparenz und
umfassender begründung den deutschen zu
erklären welche maßnahmen man aus
welchem grund für erforderlich hält
bund und länder setzen also vor allem
auf kontakt beschränkungen zur pandemie
bekämpfung für wie lange und in welchem
umfang genau darauf soll es noch heute
antworten geben tja noch heute liebe
nicole noch eine frage an dich was
glaubst du denn wann ist es soweit dass
das ist überhaupt noch nicht abzusehen
das ist einer dieser abende die wir hier
wirklich nicht schätzen im
hauptstadtstudio der kann sich nämlich
total lange ziehen
es kann auch noch kann auch ganz schnell
jetzt innerhalb der nächsten stunde die
an
einigung geben dass es die verkündigung
gibt irgendwelche ergebnisse oder das
ergebnis ist dass man kein ergebnis
erzielt hat
man weiß es einfach nicht sagte ich auch
nicht gerne sagen wir an dieser stelle
vielen dank nicole und hoffen dass wir
uns sehr bald wieder sprechen um dann
ergebnisse mit dir einordnen zu können
vielen dank nicole und es später und
herr doktor stimme wir machen hier im
studio weiter mit einer frage von emilia
b die uns über youtube schreibt wird es
eine dritte welle geben oder wird davon
ausgegangen dass es vorher den impfstoff
gibt ja wenn ich das wüsste
müsste man jetzt schöne kugel
wahrscheinlich den stellen reinschauen
also ihr habt ja vorhin schon mal
angedeutet im gespräch ist steht und
fällt immer damit wie wir als
einzelperson in dieser pandemie damit
umgehen wie viel eigenverantwortung wir
tatsächlich wahrnehmen wie stark uns
bewusst ist dass wir durch unser eigenes
handeln
diese ganze pandemie ein bisschen mit
kontrollieren können natürlich könnten
wir eine dritte welle vermeiden wenn wir
jetzt in diesem lockdown zum einen sehen
dass die zahlen deutlich fallen wenn wir
dann nach vier wochen beschließen die
maßnahmen wieder zurückgefahren wenn
dann jeder wieder in seinen alten trott
verfällt wenn jeder wieder die kontakte
so sucht wie er sie vor der zweiten
welle gesucht hat weil wo ist die zweite
welle hierher gekommen
dann werden wir eine dritte welle
erleben und das gilt es eigentlich zu
vermeiden wenn man nicht eben diese new
york down effekt immer wieder haben
wollen
es liegt an uns allen wir können diese
welle vermeiden indem wir eben nach
diesen locker und jetzt einfach nicht in
das alte verhaltensmuster zurückfallen
und sofort wieder unsere ganzen kontakte
nach holen die wir jetzt in den vier
wochen nicht sehen durften noch eine
andere frage kommt auch über youtube
wenn die fw fragt was kommt danach das
virus geht hier steht nicht weg das
macht eigentlich keinen sinn es müsste
heißen das virus geht weg es kommt ein
neues und dann was machen wir denn dann
wir haben letztendlich hat sich in der
nachkriegszeit ja noch nie so was erlebt
wie jetzt mit sauerstoff zwei insofern
es ist natürlich so dass immer wieder
neue erreger kommen
wir haben die schweinegrippe inzwischen
deutlich mal gehabt wir haben vorher das
saß einst gehabt
das wird uns unterschiedlich stark
beschäftigen dass wir jetzt ein so
massives virus haben in unserer pandemie
sagt pandemie form das ist nicht
alltäglich und man muss einfach in der
zukunft abwarten was uns erwartet es
kann uns immer wieder passieren dass wir
noch mal so was erleben
ich wünsche es mir nicht aber wenn man
realistisch ist das ist durchaus möglich
nun ist eine frage die auch immer wieder
auftaucht die nach dem gesundheitssystem
und eine nach den intensivstationen und
es gibt hier eine frage auch über
youtube von chorus kabir ist die
intensivbetten auslastung des jahres
2020 deutlich höher als in den jahren
zuvor
dazu gibt es eine zahl derzeit gibt es
3500 19 patienten auf intensivstationen
das sind 20 prozent mehr als bei der
ersten welle im frühjahr das den zahlen
die heute die deutsche
krankenhausgesellschaft veröffentlicht
hat und auf den normalen stationen der
kliniken befinden sich derzeit 15.000
cupid 19 patienten wie sehr besorgt sie
die lage in den krankenhäusern im moment
ja ich glaube das ist ein punkt den
viele ein bisschen unterschätzt haben
aufgrund der guten situationen die wir
letztendlich im sommer gehabt haben da
man ja kaum menschen auf die
intensivstation gesehen kurve assoziiert
aber es war uns über kurz oder lang mehr
als klar dass das ganze passieren muss
weil wir können das infektionsgeschehen
nicht von der älteren bevölkerung
fernhalten wenn wir eben im land über
20.000 neuinfektionen pro tag haben dann
war es nur eine frage der zeit bis sich
wieder mehr ältere menschen infizieren
damit wieder mehr menschen schwerere
verläufe haben auf die intensivstation
kommen und versterben werden das ist
sehr trauriger trend der aber abzusehen
war und auch gerade dass die zahlen die
werden auch noch die nächsten wochen
weiter nach oben laufen weil diese
intensivstation und sterbefälle ja der
infektionszahlen noch weiter hinten
dranhängen und das macht mich schon
macht mir schon sorgen weil wir ja auch
vielerorts die signale bekommen dass
diese freien betten ja nicht wirklich
echt freie betten in der form sind dass
sie auch betreut werden können das nützt
mir dann wenn ich an intensiv bett habe
und da stehen vielleicht auch ein paar
automaten dabei ich habe kein personal
was dieses intensiv betreut und insofern
im markt die zahl auch ein bisschen
überschätzt worden seien und die reale
die zahl der intensivbetten ist auch
noch mal etwas geringer und das was ich
von vielerorts höre ist eben dass die
situation durchaus schon so ist dass wir
eben in den intensivstationen zu laufen
und wir sind noch nicht am ende
wir schauen uns genau an dieser fälle
jetzt mal an und zwar gehen wir in den
landkreis mühldorf am inn
wir können uns hier über die heute de
die karte mal anschauen
hier sehen wir die deutsche karte und in
den kreisen wo es dunkelblau ist ist das
dunkelrot also wir haben hier sehr hohe
fallzahlen bautzen zum beispiel 338
fälle je 100.000 einwohner
und dann gehen wir nach mühldorf am inn
hier ist es uns sehen ist hier sind 252
fälle je 100 1 je 100.000 einwohner und
das ist tatsächlich ein landkreis in dem
die krankenhäuser an ihre grenzen stoßen
und das schauen wir uns jetzt mal an
die intensivstation des klinikums
mühldorf mit aller kraft stemmen sie
sich gegen die welle schon jetzt geraten
sie hier an ihre grenzen
wir haben das ganze haus mit älteren
menschen von uns kann jeden tag
passieren dass die halter auf die
beratungs station müssen und beatmet
werden müssen und irgendwann wenn man
dann mit den betten klassen 8 schwer
kranke patienten werden aktuell beatmet
der kampf gegen das virus er ist
zermürbend und manches mal nicht zu
gewinnen heute nacht wieder in jungen
und 50 jahre alt vier menschen sterben
hier nur in unserem bei sein und ohne
schranke eine extreme physische und
psychische belastung erstmals werden die
patienten in die partner klinik
altötting verlegt auch um das
klinikpersonal zu entlasten
man war es das circa vier bis sechs
punkte monate vor uns liegen dass sich
diese entwicklung fortsetzen wird
entsprechend ist dort natürlich auch
eine große angst bei unseren
mitarbeitern was aktuell bei uns schon
passiert und was sich in den nächsten
wochen auch zuspitzen würde die
angespannte situation in der klinik
spiegelt das infektionsgeschehen im
landkreis wieder seit einiger zeit liegt
die inzidenz zahl bei etwa 250
infizierten pro 100.000 einwohnern in
sieben tagen
wer natürlich macht mir als wenn ich da
sehe was enough intensiv legte leuten
und ziemlich im sommer das tor geht
jeder ist ein unvorsichtiger wand und ja
es ist wohl leider nach hinten
losgegangen ist von derzeit gesprochen
worden aber doch zum teil dass wir
politisch muss dafür aber es ist wohl
doch trotz aller anstrengungen des
gesundheitsamts lassen sich die
infektionsketten auch hier wieder schwer
verfolgen wir sind ja definitiv auf
anschlag wir müssen die zahlen jetzt
wieder nach unten bekommen im grunde
genommen ist das infektionsgeschehen
jetzt auf dem ganzen landkreis fläche
verteilt umso wichtiger sei es dass die
strengen maßnahmen eingehalten werden
denn ansonsten gibt es keine chance
gegen das wie
der herr doktor stürmer das sind bilder
die uns an den frühling erinnern als wir
diese bilder aus bergamo gesehen haben
die auch wahrscheinlich im wesentlichen
dazu beigetragen haben dass die menschen
sich an diese ganzen beschränkungen
gehalten haben da muss man vorsichtig
sein man darf das heute nicht
vergleichen mit damals man darf auch mit
diesen bildern keine panik schüren
aber die situation ist ja so wie sie ist
und sie haben auch gerade ihre sorge
geäußert dass sie sich noch
verschlimmert ich möchte vor diesem
hintergrund gerne noch mal das große
thema aufgreifen was in diesem chat eine
große rolle spielt nämlich die schulen
das bewegt einfach die meisten leute und
ich glaube dass sie im frühjahr auch
alle so zu hause geblieben sind weil sie
zu hause sein mussten für die kinder ja
zu hause waren und betreut werden
mussten und weil es auch einfach ein
anderes gefühl war es waren viel weniger
leute auf den straßen und die schüler
hatten natürlich auch nicht den impuls
zu sagen wir haben uns ja heute morgen
in der schule gesehen also können wir
uns ja heute nachmittag auch verabreden
das fragen auch sehr viele user zum
beispiel warum darf mein kind mit 20
leuten in der klasse sitzen und danach
nur noch einen freund besuchen das ist
eine der maßnahmen die heute mal in der
luft lag die aber offenbar wieder vom
tisch sind
und auf youtube fragt auch jemanden
namens gegen denken die öffnung der
schulen führt doch zu einer weitläufigen
verbreitung des virus in den schulen
treffen sich schüler aus tausenden von
clustern
warum wird das ignoriert können sie zum
infektionsgeschehen einfach noch mal was
sagen vielleicht haben sie haben das ja
schon gesagt aber vielleicht gewinnt
auch viele neu dazu gekommen die das
noch nicht gehört haben ja also es ist
natürlich absolut berechtigt wäre haben
verschiedene systeme die die werde ich
gleichwertig behandeln wir lassen in den
schulen die kinder miteinander agieren
und zu hause oder sollen sie sich auf
das minimum beschränken jetzt muss man
halt natürlich noch mal ein bisschen
differenzieren weil eine schule ist ja
doch ein etwas kontrollierter raum als
als zu hause sage ich mal so auch wenn
natürlich so eine schule auch ein
ziemlich chaotisch ist mit enten da sein
kann aber es gibt natürlich trotzdem
klare regeln
ganz wichtig ist erstmal zu verstehen
kinder sind durchaus in der lage das
virus zu bekommen und kinder sind auch
durchaus in der lage das virus weiter zu
geben das muss man ganz klar sagen wir
sehen auch jetzt gerade die aktuellen
steigerungsraten bei den kindern bei den
jugendlichen meine kleinen kindern auch
die gehen sukzessive nach oben
und deswegen muss man die schulen und
die kindergärten sehr ernst nehmen was
das infektionsgeschehen angeht und muss
sehr genau hingucken was dort passiert
wir haben eine nicht unerhebliche gefahr
dadurch dass die kinder im unterricht
die masken nicht aufsetzen weil es ein
geschlossener raum der möglicherweise so
optimal belüftet ist und die kinder
sitzen über einen längeren zeitraum
miteinander da insofern ist die
diskussion die ja zum teil auch schon
umgesetzt worden ist maske im unterricht
aufzusetzen sicherlich eher zielführend
auf der anderen seite ist es ja so wenn
die kinder dann die schule verlassen
dann passierte eine ganz andere
unkontrollierte situation also ich hab
selber erlebt dann ist das schultor
hinter sich gelassen da wird die maske
herunter genommen und dann macht man im
prinzip was man will
und all das was man vorher sechs stunden
konsequent durchgezogen hat ist platz
den nächsten fünf minuten komplett
vergessen
insofern haben wir einfach eine
diffizile situation und da gehen wir
wieder in die eigenverantwortung da muss
mal wieder argumentieren und sagen es
hilft nix auf der einen seite ist so zu
machen und auf der anderen macht das so
da kann man das glaube ich gar nicht so
sehr durch regeln und verbote irgendwie
steuern sondern es muss in die köpfe
rein dass wir uns in der bestimmte art
und weise verhalten müssen in der schule
und zu hause genauso
nun gibt es ja aber sachen die man gar
nicht ändern kann selbst wenn man sie
wollte zum beispiel schreibt markus buck
auch über youtube wie hoch ist denn die
ansteckungsgefahr in überfüllten
linienbussen
denn das ist ja auch eine situation die
man vor der schule und nach der schule
hat alle auf abstand dann fallen sie
sich vielleicht erst mal in die arme zum
abschied und dann stehen sie wie die
ölsardinen im bus vielleicht mit maske
aber halt natürlich völlig ohne abstand
auch eine absolut berechtigte kritik und
das doch auch das ist ja schon vielfach
gefordert worden dass man auch einfach
da sich gedanken machen muss wie man das
ganze entzerrt dass eben nicht alle in
einen bus gehen das ist ja unabhängig
von der schule der gesamte öffentliche
so nahm verkehr hat ja das problem das
daher teilweise die die züge viel zu
voll sind und da sind alle beteiligten
aufgefordert eben maßnahmen zu finden
entweder die taktfrequenz zu erhöhen
teilweise züge länger zu machen oder
eben einen gestaffelten schulschluss
einzurichten dass eben nicht alle in den
gleichen bus stürmen sondern dass es
eben besser verteilt wird auch da wieder
die kritik von vorhin man hat lange
lange zeit gehabt sich da was zu
überlegen dann hat er den ganzen sommer
die ganzen sommerferien zeit sich
gedanken zu machen
uns ging es im sommer zu gut deswegen
hat man das problem so ein bisschen vor
sich hergeschoben
man hat auch sicherlich die annahme
gehabt dass kinder nicht so sehr zum
infektionsgeschehen beitragen und
hoffnung kindergarten eher unkritisch
sind mit sehen heute dass es nicht der
fall ist und jetzt sind wir natürlich
spät dran das ist müßig darüber zu
meckern
ich habe es trotzdem noch mal kurz getan
weil es mich auch immer wieder ärgert
als mit betroffener vater eines eines
schulkindes da hat man einfach viel zeit
verstreichen lassen und muss jetzt im
nachhinein versuchen schnell gestrickte
lösung zu machen wir wissen ja alle was
man ad hoc schnell macht ist oft nicht
ganz optimal im kanzleramt sehen es
hinter uns
wenn neue fotomotive ausprobiert aber
auch das ist nicht das worauf wir alle
warten während wir nach berlin blicken
würde ich gerne den blick noch mal
weiter werfen auf ein fest dass
bevorsteht das auf das wir uns
eigentlich alle freuen nämlich
weihnachten und jetzt ist die große
frage die wir heute noch nicht
beantworten können was wird da möglich
sein was was darf man was darf man nicht
aber gibt es aus biologischer sicht eine
korrekte art weihnachten zu feiern
angenommen wir durften uns sehen
angenommen das wäre erlaubt verschiedene
haus stände dürfen sich treffen die
familie feiert zusammen sitzen wir dann
alle mit maske mit abstand um einen sehr
großen baum habe sich der abstand
gewahrt bleibt oder wer welche
möglichkeiten sehen sie da ganz
praktisch keine alle fragen sind erlaubt
alle anderen auch ne also ganz schwer
vorzustellen also das rein biologischer
sicht je kleiner der crysis mit dem man
sich trifft umso besser ist es natürlich
da
möchte jetzt natürlich nicht jeder hören
jeder möchte gerne doch sich mit
mehreren leuten ist es völlig klar es
ist ein familienfest und die familie
besteht nicht nur aus den aus dem
partner und den kindern oder den den
allernächsten verwandten soll man möchte
eigentlich da ein bisschen mehr ich kann
aufgrund der aktuellen situation stand
jetzt einfach nur sagen es ist ein
besonderes weihnachten im negativen
sinne es ist ein besonderes jahr gewesen
in vielerlei hinsicht aus negativen
sinne
und wir haben nicht viele möglichkeiten
was zu machen ich kann mir schwer
vorstellen dass man wirklich weihnachten
feiern möchte mit abstand und maske das
wäre aber im prinzip die option
vielleicht sind wir inzwischen dann
schon so weit dass der antigen schnell
teste flächendeckender eingesetzt werden
kann möglicherweise eben auch in dem
kontext sich möglicherweise eben für
solche feste frei 1003 testen lassen zu
können
wir gehen falls auch auf eigene kosten
ich weiß nicht in welche ideen das ganze
noch gehen wird
theoretisch wäre es möglich abgesehen
davon dass der schnelltest halt nicht
tatsächlich an privatpersonen also das
kann man sich im augenblick abschminken
dass man sagt ich bestellen bei amazon
oder wo auch immer im online-handel zehn
schnelltests wir testen uns mal kurz
frei und feiern dann zusammen
unbeschwert weihnachten das ist leider
nicht möglich
vielleicht gibt es da aber trotzdem
ideen dass man das ganze sicherer macht
durch eben eine bestimmte tests
strategie aber im augenblick sind wir im
labor absolut am anschlag was das testen
angeht dass sie sich da er kein
spielraum ist über diese möglichkeit zu
machen aber wenn man schon ein bisschen
in die glaskugel schauen wir haben ja
noch ein paar wochen zeit vielleicht
gibt es da doch noch irgendwo die ein
oder andere möglichkeit dass auf diese
art zu machen ansonsten knapp halten so
knapp ist und eben dann doch kontakte
körperliche kontakte soweit vermeiden
wie es geht
regelmäßiges lüften und das ist das
beste was man letztendlich dann machen
kann
daneben blicken wir doch einfach auf den
nächsten christlichen feiertag der dann
vor uns liegt das wäre ostern
vorausgesetzt bis ostern
vorausgesetzt man ist chris und feiert
ostern aber wenn es bis dahin einen
impfstoff gibt wie wahrscheinlich für
wie wahrscheinlich halten sie das dass
das vor ostern der fall sein könnte und
dann möchte ich gerne den kommentar von
aus youtube mit einbeziehen mit dem
sinnigen namen radfahrer ohne motor
könnt ihr etwas über den heute neu
berichteten impfstoff sagen es ist eine
anspielung auf den impfstoff des
us-konzerns moderner ich hoffe wir
werden das richtig ausgesprochen
der heute an die presse ging mit einem
impfstoff der bei einer wirksamkeit von
94,5 prozent liegen soll wie schätzen
sie diese meldung ein
und ich würde sie jetzt erst mal in die
gleiche schublade packen wie die
biontech meldung die wir vor kurzem
gehört haben sind presse mitteilungen in
dem er erst mal noch keine studiendaten
wirklich sehen können und ohne die
detaillierten daten ist es schwierig
abzuschätzen was die impfstoffe wirklich
leisten auf der anderen seite sind das
erst mal auch sehr gute signale
das ist also man soll das nicht immer
alles schlecht reden und immer mehr
daten fordern erstmal sind das gute
nachrichten weil 94% 90 prozent sind
sehr gute zahlen werden deutlich weniger
gerechnet
die impfstoff technik also die
sogenannte messenger rna technik haben
beide firmen gemeinsam dass sie also auf
dieser basis diesen impfstoff entwickelt
haben darf ich dann war da ja da gibt es
immer gegner die sagen das ist ein ganz
neuer impfstoff das wurde noch nie
ausprobiert das ist total gefährlich
laster bloß die finger von
was verstehen die menschen unter
ausprobiert die das jetzt fordern also
ausprobiert im menschen heißt ja es ist
schon ausprobiert worden wir haben ja
erst mal diese phase eins und zwei
studien schon hinter uns und da haben
wir keine schwerwiegenden signale draus
gesehen also es ist schon im menschen
probiert vorn was die technik angeht die
hat man vorher in sich versuchen
experimentell als als sicher
charakterisieren können und da rein aus
der der molekularbiologischen sicht was
dort passiert wir nehmen ein ganz
kleines schnäpschen der erbinformation
vom virus kein vollständiges virus gehen
oder kommt die komplette erstinformation
vom virus will mal ganz kleines
stückchen von einem bestimmten
oberflächenproteinen das virus und
dieses schnipseln übersetzen wir in eine
sogenannte messenger rna eine boten rna
diese boten rna macht in unserer
körperzellen wenn sie dort mal rein
gekommen ist